[Music]
to me and reinvention really means
resilience to all of the events that
come your way I'm being able to flow
around them and deal with them and turn
them into positives instead of the
negatives they may have been
[Music]
when I first left Dropbox to start a
company I think I was overconfident I
was like you know I can do this I've
seen how it's done but it turned out to
be really hard and two or three months
in we realized some of the things we had
planned technically we're not going to
work and so I felt pretty hopeless it
took a while for me to get through this
kind of trough of despair and and get to
a place where I was not reacting so much
to all of the problems that crop up
every single day I think the the thing
that really made a difference for me was
instead of viewing problems coming in as
problems reframing it and thinking to
myself you know I'm here to learn and
every problem is a way for me to learn
more having this mentality allowed us to
eventually find sorcerous and grow it to
where we are today I think probably one
of the biggest challenges is the level
of uncertainty you have when you're
starting something that's brand new and
especially brand new in technology you
know a lot of the stuff that we're doing
is not something that has ever been done
before and so there's a big open
question as to whether it's even
possible you know to achieve the
outcomes that we ultimately want to
achieve
a lot of it is about maintaining a
stable psychology even when there's a
lot of fear or when there are security
breaches and or peat and really negative
PR all of those things won't shake a
fundamentally good business
you